when i get home from work tonight a
thick pile of mail will be waiting for
me
i wasn't
look this just arrived in my mailbox
i don't know what's in here i i maybe
there could be a letter from my grandma
there could be a an important tax
document maybe my driver's license
renewal came through and it's in here
i have no idea unless i sift through
every bit of this paper
to find it and that makes me mad it
really makes me mad and that's why
that's why i'm here
same thing applies to my phone i get 10
calls a day
from robots someone has access to me to
my eyes
my attention and i never gave them
permission to have that access
hello hello most of the time they just
hang up too much of my life is spent
sifting through information that i don't
want to look at
and that's a frustrating fact
you know you could do a buy one get one
free of dial soap
this week it's pretty cool
i'm tired i am tired of corporations
having access to my
personal attention which is already
fleeting and fractured
and split between a million things it's
like
i don't want these guys adding more to
that so i am going
on a quest to rid my life
of junk mail in all forms
yeah i'd like to cancel my mail
certainly how long would you like us to
hold it
i went out permanently i'll handle this
violet
it is a journey that has taken me down
some really weird
paths all over the internet talking to
robocall people
learning about this crazy shadowy
industry of
people who sell and buy your information
but before i can really rid my life of
junk mail i have to understand
where this all came from how does this
industry work
and how does all of this stuff end up in
my life
and that's what this video is about
buckle up the avalanche of junk mail is
more than just an annoyance
i get so much junk mail it's
unbelievable
they have a list of every mailing
address in the united states
everybody works in a post office as an
alien
okay let me just start off by saying i'm
not angry at all advertising
i'm fine with most advertising in fact
my job
relies on advertising you probably
watched a pre-roll ad before watching
this video to help pay my bills
okay in fact advertising has allowed a
lot of really wonderful things on the
internet you can
read the news for free because of
advertising all of your social media
activity
is sponsored by the ads that pass
by you and i'm fine with that there are
so many different ways
companies try to get your attention so
that you will buy their product
and most of these i'm totally fine with
but i draw a really important
line here on this side i will call the
public space advertising
all of the things that come into your
purview
when you are sort of on someone else's
space you're either driving down the
road or you're scrolling
on a free website or you're reading the
news for free or you're scrolling your
social feed or you're watching
a free video on youtube
this is sort of a consensual exchange
where you're saying i'm going to use
this
service and in exchange i'm willing to
be
served ads okay that's like seems like
really fair if you don't like it you
don't have to use
the service but there's a red line here
and on this side of the red line
are three sacred spaces my mailbox
my phone and my email inbox my phone is
where like my mom
calls me or where i have conversations
with my sister or my close friends it's
direct access
to like my pocket it is a very
personal space my mailbox is again a
personal space it's at my physical home
where i live not everyone should have
access to
that thing that is attached to my house
without my consent and then of course
my email my email is where i do my job
it's where i communicate with the people
who are closest to me i don't want just
anyone to be able to appear
at will in my inbox so those are the
three spaces that i consider sacred
all other advertising and marketing i'm
totally down with i have no
issues with but unfortunately these
three spaces
are the holy grail for advertisers you
probably know that it's really a numbers
game it's all about sending out just
as many mail pieces as you can to almost
sort of force people to notice the mail
piece
what this form of advertising is called
the stuff i have problems with
it's called direct advertising this is
the type of marketing
that aims to get right in front of a
human being
in their most personal spaces so today
you have these
massive companies that you've never
heard about that
spend day and night scraping every piece
of information from the entire world
that they can get that has to do with
you
and your behavior your interests where
you live
how you consume things where you shop
what your income level is
and they go to really great lengths to
do this sometimes they buy it
from companies who you've done some sort
of transaction with
or sometimes they'll go to public
records like real estate records to see
when was the last time you bought a
house
driver's license records voting
registration even the census can be used
to profile certain neighborhoods and
what they do is they take a bunch of
these profiles
and they put it onto a giant list and
then they can sell this list
so if i'm geico and i want to run a
marketing campaign i'm going to buy a
big list from one of these data brokers
i can say with a pretty firm certainty
that every person watching this video
has an extensive profile on one of these
lists
that is owned by these big data
brokerages that you've never heard of
and this information is being bought and
sold every day
to large companies it's a very lucrative
industry but wait
i thought there's been all this stuff in
the news about how like we're tightening
up privacy
and like the mismanagement of data and
like tech companies are being cracked
down on and
isn't this all tightening up and our
data is actually more protected than
ever
yes but but actually no
oh i'm really behind the eight ball mac
the mail doesn't stop bud
you smoking now let's use an example
that has to do with an app i use a lot
doordash doordash is a meal delivery app
when you sign up you give them your
address
and your telephone number and all the
information they need to know to deliver
you
food i'm fine with that but as you get
ready to actually sign up
of course you see this familiar box of
terms of use and privacy statement
no one reads that i don't read that
until i decided to read it and see
what's going on what's doordash doing
with all this information
you'll see that doordash can use your
data to serve you ads
again i'm fine with that it's like go
ahead track my behavior and
cater ads to me i'm totally okay with
that but what you don't realize when
you're using doordash
is that all of this data of your
behavior
and everything that's linked to you is
also being tracked
by a bunch of other third-party apps
that
doordash has baked into their app but
here's the thing
doordash promises in its privacy
statement that they will never
take my data and all this information
and sell it to the big bad data brokers
but wait go down a little further and
you see that they
wash their hands of responsibility of
what these third-party apps do with your
data
and they suggest that you go read the
privacy statement of those third parties
those nine different companies that are
taking my data all have privacy
statements
and they want me to go read each one of
them and oh by the way
i have no way of knowing who those
companies are or what data they're
collecting
total nightmare those companies could
easily be taking all of this data they
have
free rein on and selling it to the
highest bidder and it would still be
within the terms of use
and the privacy statement of doordash
let's just pause here for a second and
let me remind you that again i don't
necessarily have a problem with people
knowing that i like
sushi if it just means i'm gonna get
more tailored ads when i'm like
scrolling through facebook that's fine
it doesn't necessarily violate my
redline
the big problem here and where it starts
to get into my red line
is that all of this data eventually will
make it to
a data broker who will add it to my big
profile suddenly they know i like sushi
and before you know it
more of this is arriving on my doorstep
that's where it crosses my red line
and that's why i'm frustrated that
they're not actually making anyone stand
accountable for what they do with my
data what i'm about to talk about
is where it starts to get egregious and
actually makes my blood boil a little
bit
and that has to do with the united
states postal service
the postal service is prohibited from
selling or renting mailing lists they
have their own statute on this besides
the privacy act
now i don't know how this works in other
countries and honestly i would love to
know but you know the swiss
uh postal service will actually ask you
do you want this junk mail delivered and
if you don't
they'll keep it for you and they'll
recycle it but i'm just gonna explain
how it works here and
hope that this isn't the case everywhere
else the postal service promises me on
their website that they would never
sell my personal information they're a
freaking government agency like
they're not they shouldn't be selling
where i live thank you postal service
that is the respectful thing to do
in fact there's actually a law in the
united states that says the postal
service can't exploit
my personal information by selling it to
these data brokers so we should be good
right government agency
there's a law my taxpayer money pays for
them
we're good right no the postal service
has found a sneaky way around
this law it's just it's like so sleazy
it's just i don't know if i can talk
about it without like
being angry here in the united states
it's estimated that like
a fifth of the population moves houses
every year it's an estimate but it's a
lot of people
millions and millions tens of millions
of people move
change addresses when they do that they
want their mail to not go to the old
address where they used to live they
want it to be forwarded to their new
address
you can go onto the postal service
website and you can create a request
that says
when mail comes to my old house forward
it to my new house
it's really nice it's a great service
and i'm very excited in fact i had to go
through this recently because we're
moving
so i forwarded all my mail filled it out
was ready to go
thank you postal service okay so here's
the sleazy part
the postal service takes that
information that i gave them when i told
them hey i'm moving to this new address
and they create a giant database of
every single person who has moved in the
u.s
in the past four years and then
they sell it to the freaking data
brokers like this
they just like full-on license this list
to the data brokers
and you're like wait isn't that against
the law aren't they aren't they like
selling my personal information well as
one guy who we interviewed for this
video stated
if you say to them well you're selling
lists they say no no no no we're not
doing that we're just correcting lists
you look at this more catalogs we are
just
helping these data brokers update their
giant list
of every address in the entire country
we're just helping them update it to
notify them
of exactly who you are and where you
moved
to these data brokers license this list
for like
the tune of 200 000 to get access to
this list and it's totally worth it i
thought i was going to be sort of
escaping the junk mail thing when we
moved
no because i filled out this forwarding
address thing
all of the data brokers now know exactly
where i'm moving to
freaking post office i thought we were
friends
i thought i funded you with my taxpayer
money
for the past two years i have been
thinking about
what it would take to completely rid my
life
of all of this communication not a
single piece of junk mail arrives to my
mailbox my inbox is completely free of
everything besides what i actually want
to see and my phone is a space where i
get phone calls that i actually want to
answer it's been an exhausting journey
and if enough people comment about this
and like want to hear about what that is
i will
gladly make the video
i believe that our attention is valuable
that what we decide to pay attention we
use that word pay
because it's like we are giving a finite
resource
to something what we decide to pay
attention to matters and
we live in a world that increasingly
values that attention and creates
products that are optimized to lock it
in
and to steal that attention without
consent
that's disturbing to me and so when i
look at this
it's not really about this it's about
the principle
of my finite attention being
taken up by someone i didn't give
permission
to it's a broader effort i'm making in
my life and one that i feel like is very
necessary
to choose the things that i pay
attention to as opposed to letting those
things
choose me
i hope this video was helpful and
enlightening in some way
and um i am really interested in hearing
your your feedback today's video is
sponsored by
storyblocks who you've heard me talk
about before i'm a giant fan of
storyblocks
i've been using storybox for many years
well before they
ever came to me to sponsor a video and
that's because they are
really the best stock footage company
out there that you can pay
so little for and get so much from
they have a giant library of stock
footage of all kind some of which i used
for this video
every video i make i find myself on
storyblocks looking for footage to help
beef up the visuals because i can't go
everywhere
and film everything myself and yet for
like a monthly cost of a subscription
you have unlimited access to all of this
stuff and it's not just stock footage
it's sound effects
it's after effects templates it's a
bunch of tools that as a creator
are incredibly useful to have at my desk
when i'm trying to make stuff there's a
link in my description
when you click that link it helps
support this channel but it's where you
can go to sign up for
storyblocks if you're a creator this is
a no-brainer
to have access to all of this extra
visual material to help beef up your
videos so click the link in the
description thank you storyblocks for
supporting this video and supporting
this channel
i really appreciate that and thank you
all for watching
i'm gonna keep going on my quest to get
rid of junk mail and
it's hard and exhausting but it's also
something i'm
fairly dedicated to as you've seen in
this video so
have a good day
that's great